[Music]
[Applause]
Dan orlovsky of the mothership joining
us on the program uh let me start with
that you know the NFL is trying to reach
out to its players but is there a better
way to go about telling about the evils
of gambling
yeah I honestly thought Dan that the
Calvin Ridley suspension would have
pretty big impact you know for to lose a
season to lose the amount of money that
he did and the prime of his career I
thought that would kind of make people
take a step back and make what am I
really doing
um
it's I think it's really hard for the
NFL to
get everybody
to have no
um interaction with gambling when the
NFL is an organization or or a product
has a tremendous impact or tremendous
interaction with gambling so how do they
get it better
um
I think it's almost impossible candidly
with the with the access that we have to
gambling how easy it is
um and no nobody thinks they're gonna
get caught but I would have had Calvin
Ridley front and center and said hey
part of your rehab and coming back to
the NFL is you talk to the rookies at
this Symposium and tell him that you
lost 11 million dollars by betting you
know fifteen hundred dollars that's how
quickly it can happen and go away yeah
and I I think that that would be the one
moment because the NFL we would have
people come speak to us not even when we
were rookies annually about all of that
stuff about injuries and
um you know what happens if you get
injured and how you can you can um get
player compensation or in so many
different different Avenues we would
have people come talk to us and remind
us about the money that we can make or
the money that we're potential the odor
what should we do with the 401K and what
you so and I don't know if they did that
stuff with the gambling I've been out of
it for a couple years now so I don't
know but having Calvin sit there and be
like guys 11 million dollars that's more
than 99 of you guys are gonna make in
your career I mean I lost it in one year
so there's got to be a better way
um for them to do it and for to get the
players to really grasp the magnitude of
it but I just think it's impossible to
think you're gonna get to every single
one what's the number one topic story
here in the off season with the NFL
yeah probably still the Jet Center in
Rogers and are they as good as they
should be you know I think that
um you know
Aaron going to the Jets immediately
votes them into the conversation with
the the Kansas City Chiefs and I don't
know if we've really
appreciated how big a deal that is we're
talking about a team that's gone to the
AFC title game five years in a row we're
talking they're they are
a pseudo Dynasty maybe they're not the
New England Patriots for 20 years
Dynasty and to think that one 40 year
old quarterback coming to A Team
immediately puts that team there with
the one that's gone to five AFC title
games that's a really big deal and but
do you believe that accurate do you
believe what's that oh so you believe
the Jets are right there on the same
level with the Chiefs I think they are I
think the Buffalo Bills are
um obviously the off the field stuff
that Buffalo is is handling that's
that's got to get handled
um the Bengals are you know we got to
see their young secondary
um and I'd say the second thing is
Jordan love I mean I think they're
attached you know how good is Jordan
love how good is Jordan love going to be
because the the funny thing Dan is we
only talk about in the NFC we talk about
Philly in San Francisco right now we'll
sprinkle in Detroit we'll sprinkle in
Seattle what happens if Jordan loves
really good
well you're going to the NFC title game
two out of last four years in Green Bay
that's still a really talented football
team if Jordan loves really good they're
right there
but you would put Dallas in there as
well wouldn't you
yeah no doubt absolutely Dallas is a
good football
in in my eyes comes down to two people
obviously the quarterback I don't need
to tell anybody that
mozzie Smith their first round draft
pick if Dallas can't get better at
stopping the run on early Downs
it doesn't matter how good Micah Parsons
is at Rushing the passer it doesn't
matter how good Demarcus Lawrence is by
rushing to pass her because they won't
get into those situations consistently
enough for it to matter you got to stop
Philly in San Francisco both of them
excel at running the football
we're talking to Dan orlonsky ESPN
football analyst I was wondering about
Tom Brady's role with the Raiders why
would you buy in or become a minority
owner or be part of the process but not
really be part of the process he said
that he's not going to be involved or
that involved he's so competitive how
does Brady be involved but not you know
hands on day to day
yeah I think it's going to be really
difficult for him to transition to you
know just being a person sitting on the
back burner knowing what he's
accomplished in his career
um there's probably no better world to
be in than professional sports ownership
right now across any League you know
it's just blowing up so that's probably
the Genesis of why he got into it why
would you not also want Tom involved Tom
Hanks yeah seen and experienced and
accomplished everything in that world so
why would you not I think it'll be very
difficult for him to just sit back and
and watch a franchise make this decision
and him go I wouldn't have done that and
or or do do these things or invest into
this and be like no no we're doing it
the wrong way so now he's he's got
attachments to the head coach he's got
attachments to the general manager so
maybe he will be a little bit more
involved in publicly declaring um but I
would want Tom involved but could you
imagine he walks by a film session in or
he walks out on the field and he becomes
the best quarterback in Camp just by
walking walking past Jimmy Garoppolo
it's like yeah and just the frustration
the frustration of being like how can
you not hit that pass or how did you not
see that or absolutely or watching
Devante run wide open and him you know
check the ball down to a tailback uh the
Dalvin cook DeAndre Hopkins is is that
going to be a package deal
it depends on where you you know like I
I don't see it because I think both of
those
guys have better places for them to go
than
um where they could go together like I I
do think I've said this if I was Dallas
why would you not call Dalvin cook well
you're going into a season where you're
leading tailback just broke his leg
right now we're we're six months ago he
broke his leg
and we can sit here and forecast that
three or four months from he still broke
his leg last year okay in a pretty bad
way you're a team that's won 12 games
last two years why would you not have a
better kind of plan B
um so I think Delvin to Miami makes a
lot of sense but then you know hop
doesn't make a lot of sense in Miami he
doesn't necessarily fit what they want
to do either schematically when it comes
to kind of like the version of receiver
that they have if I was hopped New
England makes a ton of sense Baltimore
makes a ton of sense but those don't
make a ton of sense for doubt we'll cook
so I just don't think I don't see the
ideal situation where both of those guys
go together I also don't see how that
makes Financial sense for either of them
I was also wondering about it if they
did go to the same team what's the best
running back wide receiver combination
in the NFL right now oh good question
best running back well it would be Josh
Jacobs and Devonte Adams that that
that's the best tailback wide receiver
combo in the NFL
um what if I put Christian McCaffrey
Debo Samuel
right up there you know the the thing
the thing that would make those guys a
little bit different is debos not as
good as nor used the same way as Devonte
and Christians use just differently than
Josh Josh is a traditional Pound The
Rock tailback we know McCaffrey's just
get the ball in his hands type of player
but they're right up there I think those
guys would be kind of 1A 1B
um you know Tennessee with Derrick they
don't have a legit number one yet to
kind of put them into that conversation
um
and Justin Jefferson might have been
that top combo if they were still in
Minnesota totally totally they would be
right right into that they would be
right up there with Devante and Josh
Jacobs and I wonder is Justin Jefferson
going to be the highest non
quarterback in the NFL
uh yes you have to look at I I have
actually said this to Ryan Clark
multiple times like for 18 months I've
been how does Minnesota keep them
you know like how does Minnesota keep
them without paying him every single
penny that he wants he's a superstar
wide receiver he's as talented as we
have in the NFL he continues to put up
numbers he could very easily be in a
different Minnesota is an awesome place
but there's a there's other cities that
that are desirable for players to live
in and if you're adjusting and you
continue to put up these numbers you're
going to have outrageous leverage of I
don't want to maybe I don't want to live
in Minnesota anymore I don't want to
play in this with this quarterback
anymore you know so I think he he will
he will be the highest paid
non-quarterback absolutely especially in
a past League uh if you were buffalo
would you have a retire retractable roof
for a dome stadium
um
I think so I think Buffalo because of
who my quarterback is I think that they
are losing an advantage
um by not allowing weather to play its
part but also allowing weather to play
too much of a part you know what I'm
saying like you you because Josh's arm
go back to the New England game of two
years ago he has a distinct advantage
that you want whether to play a little
bit of a factor because he it doesn't
impact him that much but you also don't
want him or your team to be so hindered
by having to play in you know two feet
of snow type of thing because then that
becomes
um you're not playing to your strength
so Josh is better every quarterback is
better playing inside it's easier but I
would have the op the option if I was
Buffalo of let's leave it open and play
to our Vantage let's play Let's have it
closed and make sure that we're at least
at an even playing field
good to talk to you as always Dan thanks
for joining us thanks bud good to see
you Dan olomsky of the mothership you
can catch Dan on NFL live weekdays at
four Eastern